bonjour juste un bref merci de répondre
à nos questions sur rt france donc le
principal syndicat des médecins des
internes de médecine appel à un
confinement total et absolu ça veut dire
que jusqu'ici les mesures prises par le
gouvernement n'ont pas été assez forte
pour enrayer l'épidémie
exactement exactement on voit que les
mesures qui ont été prises en chine
notamment étaient beaucoup plus radicale
et ils ont consisté à mettre en
confinement total 58 millions de
personnes c'est à dire intervient
absolument de circuler dans la rue
interdire également toutes les
entreprises qui ne sont pas vitales pour
les personnes interdire les transports
en commun ce sont des mesures qui sont
essentiels d'une part pour ralentir la
propagation du virus mais aussi pour
réserver le matériel de protection aux
soignants qui sont actuellement dans des
situations de pénurie de matane de de
protection sur l'ensemble du territoire
alors justement ce moment même il ya un
conseil de défense à l'elysée devrait se
terminer d'ici quelques instants il ya
olivier vérone ministre de la santé qui
devrait prendre la parole
d'ici les prochaines minutes est-ce que
vous pensez que ce que vous préconisez
va être
10 par le gouvernement par notamment
olivier ferrand qu'est ce que vous
attendez de ce conseil de défense
ce qu'on attend de ce conseil de défense
c'est effectivement qui prennent ces
mesures de confinement total de la
population
il faut réaliser les recommandations oms
qui sont de réaliser un dépistage de
l'ensemble de la population et les
soignants bien sûr en priorité et on a
besoin que le masque et que les masques
et les matériels de protection sommes
mis à disposition des personnels
soignants aux priorités
si ces mesures ne sont pas prises dans
tous les cas nous avons saisi le conseil
d'état pour un recours en référé référé
liberté afin que ces mesures soient
prises
alors justement il ya trois maires
médecins qui ont porté plainte contre
agnès buzyn ancien ministre de la santé
edouard philippe
le premier ministre il les accuse de ne
pas avoir pris à temps les mesures
nécessaires quel est votre position
alors oui les mesures ont été prises
trop tard néanmoins aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le moment de régler des comptes
là il faut prendre des mesures des
mesures urgentes et si on saisit la
justice
aujourd'hui c'est pour que des mesures
urgentes soient prises qui vont
permettre aux professionnels de santé de
se protéger et donc de protéger la
population
dans quel état d'esprit et le personnel
hospitalier vous comment est ce que vous
vous sentez est ce que vous sentez vous
pouvez tenir le coup encore encore
longtemps
alors il y avait des situations
d'épuisement déjà avant l'épidémie
actuellement les professionnels sont sur
le pont sont au front sont motivés
néanmoins en as tu déjà ça un collègue
qui sont à risque d'épuisement ou en
situation d'épuisement total on a
organisé les remplacements les relais
pour pouvoir les prendre en charge au
maximum et je dois dire qu'il ya surtout
un sentiment de colère en ce moment de
colère très intense car ça fait depuis
décembre déjà même bien avant on se
plaint du manque de moyens du manque de
matériel je vous rappelle qu'on était en
grève au mois de décembre pour dénoncer
ses conditions et qu'aujourd'hui on se
retrouve à nous mettre en danger à
mettre en danger nos proches
par manque de matériel par manque de
moyens vous avez parlé du manque de
moyens le service hospitalier qui a
devrait recevoir 5 millions de dommages
là en renfort de l'armée on parle
également du million de masques venant
de la chine ce n'est pas suffisant selon
vous qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que quelle
solution à ce que vous préconisez
outre ce confinement total excusez moi
j'ai pas entendu votre question je
disais vous parlez des manques de moyens
il ya quand même eu 5 millions de
masques et en renfort de l'armée on
parle également d'un million de masques
est qui et qui vient de la chine
ce n'est donc pas pas nécessaire vous
dénoncez donc ce manque de moyens
écoutez nous on a fait des réunions avec
l'ensemble des représentants des jeunes
médecins et des médecins formation du
territoire il y avait des situations de
pénurie partout partout personne n'avait
les moyens les masques ffp2 pour se
protéger et les stocks étaient en
situation extrêmement précaire est au
coeur de la propagation épidémique je
vous rappelle que ça a commencé il ya
deux semaines les professionnels de
santé n'ont pas eu de quoi se protéger
et donc ont été contaminés et des
vecteurs de contamination
donc maintenant on met notre santé en
danger vos proches en danger
actuellement il ya 200 internes en
médecine qui sont en réanimation entre
la vie et la mort donc bien sûr que tu
vas prendre toutes les mesures possibles
mais là la principale mesure à prendre
c'est le confinement de la population
pour réserver le matériel professionnel
de santé
tout à l'heure vous parlez d'un
confinement total comme comme en chine
est ce que c'est vraiment réalisable on
a vu les
les français insouciant le week-end
dernier les certains politiques parlent
encore de france est insouciant même si
on voit comme des français à part
applaudir au balcon tous les soirs à 20h
pour remercier les professionnels de la
santé vous comment est-ce que vous jugez
les français sont ils un inconscient
insouciant ou pas du tout et ce qu'ils
ont pris la mesure de la crise sanitaire
alors je vous remercie pour cette
question j'aimerais qu'on arrête
d'accuser le peuple français d'être
insouciant ou d'être un constant je
crois que les français sont extrêmement
responsables qu'ils ont extrêmement bien
compris l'ampleur de la situation et
bien maman d'ailleurs les politiques
mais les français il écoute ce qu'on
leur dit de faire
voilà tout simplement ils ont un chef de
l'état qui leur a dit qu' il pouvait
aller dans la rue avec une simple
attestation pour aller faire du sport
ils ont vu que les transports en commun
étaient toujours ouverts donc ils les
prennent on leur dit qu'ils doivent
continuer à les travailler même si leur
emploi n'est pas vital on leur demande
de continuer à participer au chantier
des membres du gouvernement notamment
ministère du travail le monde de
continuer à participer à des chantiers
donc les français font ce qu'on leur dit
de faire
mais ils comprennent bien que ils sont
en train de mettre en danger tout le
monde c'est aux politiques au
gouvernement de prendre leurs
responsabilités et d'annoncer ce
confinement total
merci justin bras ça d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le président de l'intersyndicale